[Applaudissements]
wouah
je m'appelle reis je viens de daria aux
oreilles a conduit en français c'est
banlieue de damas je vous emmène un pot
avec moi ont serré quand j'étais au fond
j'ai passé un très bon enfant sommet il
ya un vieil homme mais ils passent dans
notre quartier avec une clochette en
fait cherche des ferrailles c'est un
business existe là bas donc nous les
gamins ont été tout petit on le donne
les moules du gâteau les chaises cassées
au des défis rail comme celle-là il
redonne de centimes
donc on achète de bonbons voilà pour ça
j'étais content mais pour aussi devenir
beaucoup pleuré je le vends dû le faire
passer de ma mère il était presque
d'informer mais c'était assez bien mais
vraiment par curiosité je suis ces
semaines qu'on fait est fait quoi avec
les déchets il est prêt à acheter de
déchets donc souvenir il fait de fortune
derrière voilà comme ça dans ma tête je
suis sur mon vélo comme l'huile en toc
toc qui roulent pas vite donc j'ai
compris qu'il faut lors de la ville ils
vont tous ces ferrailles à la tonne je
revenu assez rapide chez mon père je dit
écoute h et moi en tout cas
mais dit mais tu fais quoi avec le
docteur jeudi je veux et la ferraille
partout où je vais leur récolté revendre
m'a dit non tu passe ton bac d'abord et
après on verra un vrai entreprises on
l'achète de métal je ne suis pas contre
mon vin mauvais signe que je dois passer
mon bac
j'ai accepté plus tard
je vais vraiment entrer dans le projet à
rester dans ma tête la révolution c'est
rien arrivé
j'ai participé aux côtés mais mes amis
ma ville entier daria et evil
révolutionner on a demandé tous ensemble
les pertes et la justice
mais ça va pas marcher ont été perdus
donc ont été dégagés
heureusement on est vivant maintenant
donc
je viens vous parler et deux mille
2000 29 en 2012 je dirais l'épongé
toujours dans ma tête mais j'étais en
face à d'autres besoins vrai besoin donc
ils ont foncé rien on les bons et ils
ont un grande difficulté ont trait à
l'accès
l'école de baning donc on a construit
une école pour les enfants et plus tard
j'ai participé construit une usine où on
arrivait jusqu'à 50 employés ça veut
dire cinquante familles mais on était
plus tard empêché de travailler car
l'état libanais il ya plein de problèmes
donc l'usiné était fermée et un corps
fois j'étais exilé en turquie j'ai rien
fait
2015 je suis en france je suis descendu
de l'avion venger j'ai une énergie de
volcans
je veux entrer dans le sérail voilà la
première part hier le français deuxième
part hier je comprends pas le code bon
c'est dur donc je me suis intégré dans
plusieurs programmes incubateur
j'ai construit un carnet d'adressés
assez solide plus plus tard j'ai fait
des stages et des entreprises de déchets
j'ai bien compris donc j'ai le savoir
faire je veux commencer
et ça marche pas aussi parce que j'en ai
besoin associer les clients il me prend
pas sérieux et pense que je le parle de
la tranchée mais je suis juste là à
montreuil en fait
j'ai commencé la 7 10 filtres chercher
un associé formant cherché partout
partout chargé il ya un lien une
application sorte tender en fait pour
trouver d'associer donc je me suis
inscrit j'ai fait les choses j'ai pas
réussi aux jusqu'à 2019
je m'appelle nicolas j'ai 42 ans voilà
bon moi quand j'étais gamin
différents seuils sont demandés bon
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard je
savais pas trop et ensuite dix ans vingt
ans trente ans plus tard ça n'a pas trop
changé
alors moi j'ai un parcours classique on
va dire
universitaire j'ai fait mes classes
prépas grande école je fais un doctorat
ou en doctorat ce n'est pas facile de
trouver la motivation entre les lectures
et des références bibliographiques donc
pour m'amuser un peu j'ai monté des
projets
une vente achat du d'olive en circuit
court avec un ami berbère d'origine
berbère j'ai fait aussi librairie
associative à montreuil et j'ai créé une
maison d'édition et en 2017 on a publié
un livre sur la révolution syrienne avec
deux dans un chapitre sur daraya la
ville de rice
tout à fait par mois un connard on
arrive on j'ai engagé encore j'ai on a
fait des articles comme documentaire sur
ma ville parce qu'on a des histoires
énorme donc je vous passe est l'histoire
et
disparus donc on a fait de l'article
heureusement j'ai trouvé nicolas
bref à 39 ans j'étais à l'université je
m'ennuyais un peu et je me suis dit bon
si à 40 ans j'ai rien trouvé à
l'université j'ai pas de poste je change
complètement de parcours voilà donc en
mai au printemps 2010 9 j'ai cherché un
peu ma voix je candidate à un peu
universités mais avec l'idée en tête de
pourquoi pas changer complètement dans
l'intention en mai j'appellerai ce que
j'avais connu à travers cette histoire
de livres et je t'invite à une
présentation il me dit qu'il peut pas il
m'invite à boire un café et on s'échange
des nouvelles il me raconte une histoire
un peu farfelu de ferraille que
il veut devenir riche voire même qu'il
veut qui veut changer le monde
et qu'ils cherchent un associé bon ça
tombe bien moi je veux quelque chose de
complètement différent
l'université donc là je suis servi et je
lui dis bah raïs pourquoi cet associé
bah ça serait pas moi
honnêtement au début j'ai pas de tout
creux tout ça parce que je connais
nicolas mais pas depuis longtemps mais
je reconnais que les docteurs
universités et la maison des questions
il a rien voir de la ferraille et en
plus chez nous on fait un doctor tu te
dois voir si c'était toute la vie et
compte décide de marier tout pour entrer
chez les bonnes familles facilement
plutôt avec l'accord donc on vraiment à
tout très élevé et on t'appelle dr on
t'appelle jamais nicolas est toujours et
donc moi j'ai dit mais il est sérieux ce
mec mais je suis toujours curieux je dis
tu es le bienvenu avec ta copine chez
nous avec ma copine pourparlers à ce
sujet et ont intérêt si tu vous entrez
dans la société je t'invite inde et
n'essaie rien et il est venu jeudi si
les prêts parler devant sa famille
devant sa copine de ce projet de
ferraille se retirait voilà un bon prix
baissent pour commencer
alors on a eu ce dîner ensuite on a
commencé à discuter concrètement du
projet j'ai décidé de m'engager on s'est
associés et en août
j'ai commencé à faire le démarchage
commercial j'ai pris mon téléphone et
j'ai appelé les entreprises en leur
demandant si par hasard elle n'avait pas
de la ferraille à nous donner
j'ai déjà gagné
et ici en fait
créé l'entreprise
l'histoire
créer une entreprise en france c'est pas
du tout pareil comme entreprise même bon
si on n'a pas besoin d'avoir un
entreprise on commence au travail on
pense les gens
on vendre le produit n'achète les
machines si jamais il faut qu'on passe
aux douanes ont fait quelques papiers et
ici au fait que j'ai dit que je ne
recommencerai j'ai acheté un imprimante
j'ai commencé à imprimer des papiers des
papiers encore des papiers énorme
et après j'ai déposé les statuts chez
moi en fait
donc j'ai appelé ma famille et je dit
écoutez j'ai fait une entreprise
ils ont imaginé que je suis sur une tête
une usine de 50 salariés ou des choses
comme celles là
en vérité j'ai une imprimante j'ai un
statut
en commençant un travail trahissent je
me suis rendu compte qu'on n'avait pas
exactement la même notion du travail
l'organisation
bon au début on a décidé de déterminer
un peu les rôles de chacun on a rédigé
une sorte de pacte d'associés et
dans le pacte en préambule j'écrivais
rice et nicolas veille chacun de leur
côté
à l' équilibre entre vie professionnelle
et vie privée parce que rice allait
avoir un enfant moi j'avais toujours
d'autres engagements dont je dis
attention il faut pas que le projet
d'entreprise nous nous brûle et raissi
dit oui très bien c'est bien ici le
papier ok très bien on est d'accord et
deux jours plus tard et viens boire un
café chez moi dit vraiment nicolas c'est
très bien ce que tu as écrit serment
déchirement d'accord mais juste une
question c'est quoi la vie privée
c'était une vraie question ce que je
devais faire en france qui lient à leurs
vacances et bien carré
les jeunes réservent leur pays pour ses
vacances depuis très longtemps et je ne
sais pas c'est pas fixé comme ça en fait
il ya de vacances n'est pas fixé et donc
il ya des choses si je prononce bien rtt
aux choses comme celle-là il y a congés
il ya paternité il ya télétravail il ya
arrêt maladie mais il est pas mort le
ghana mais que le travail et aux fêtes
et donc
bon mais
j'ai pas vu que ça en fait mon père
était paysan dans le congé scolaire ou
après le colon le company alico l'on
revenait
le soir est passé mais tentons visite
même s'il dort emploie 6 mai
le soir on revient parfois hélas ses
associés parce que à côté et les
entrepreneurs et du scout le travail il
a un bon système moi je trouve bel et
bien les bris dont entre le travail et
la vie privée donc
j'ai adoré ça vraiment pour lui le
travail et c'est la vie on fait
donc j'ai dû donner certaines limites à
raïs je lui ai dit bon voilà il s'écoute
il m'appelait tout le temps ils
m'appellent il m'appelle dit lula lors
qu'on va faire je t'écoute reist je
t'aime bien
tu m'appelles autant de fois que tu veux
mais juste après 18 heures et le
week-end juste on arrête de parler de
travail
jusqu'à maintenant imminent cette phrase
en fait on vient de gagner en bourse
compris c'est important je veux pas dire
merci important compris du bureau
ouvert 24/24 cette source est ce parce
qu hors king on a déposé les ordis on a
commencé à travailler
nicolas et vient me voir me dit non ils
cotisent pour le le travail ça me sens
mon père est un coup dur ici ça va pas
comme ça je dis qu'est ce que tu veux
travail mais 10
à 17 euros ferme jeudi me laisse passer
les ouvert 10 mai nous ont fermé
ordinateur on part
hockey français te sens mieux que moi
donc on ferme en ferme m'a dit on pas
fini je vous travaillez quatre jours sur
cinq parce que j'ai une maison d'édition
j'ai d'autres choses et parfois je donne
des cours jeudi 4 sur 7
et
moi j'ai contré comme fer dans ma tête
et après il m'a dit vraiment moi j'ai
l'habitude je vous ou une semaine de
vacances je veux pas changer ça même
j'ai produit réduit mais mes vacances
pour toi merci
et g spirent est ce que je dois prendre
décision non mutation est assez rapide
direct et j'ai pris la bonne décision si
on sent parce que je veux pas qu'ils
aient des missions pour deux semaines
bon ben maintenant tu peux dire le
résultat on a du chiffre d'affaires on a
embauché alternant on a encore envie
donc on a encore plein d'espoir et c'est
plutôt un succès mais on peut faire
beaucoup mieux
voilà ça c'est raïs il a pas de limite
un jour je lui ai dit nicolas nicolas
faut qu'on réussisse il faut qu'on
réussisse vraiment et je lui dis je dis
mais reiss c'est quoi pour toi la
réussite est là il m'a dit nicolas
franchement j'ai pas le temps de me
poser ce genre de questions
non non je peux te dire avant je
continue je peux te dire en entendant le
cac40 haut que je sois le roi de
ferraille peut-être sa mort
on passa lampre travailler avec un
français comme nicolas ces appareils
impôts naturelle ou un pur mais pour moi
c'est énorme hélas pas d'accent en fait
ils parlent son accent donc personne
cross etel font qu'on le parle quand je
demande des investissements énormes en
france des investisseurs tout ça et ils
me demandent toujours est ce que tu es
tout seul au scooter en équipe et en
français vont manière directe ou
indirecte est-ce que diplômés waouh
je vous répondre à leurs questions parce
que moi je suis dans les faits des
règles j'ai besoin d'argent je je dois
annoncé l'entreprise donc j'ai comme moi
j'ai comme beaucoup dans mes recherches
l'associé je préfère qu'ils soient
français et qui soit aussi de plus mais
au contraire de moi moi je suis fâché
depuis très longtemps de l'école en fait
parce qu
une école dans un système dictatorial
ces communes présents au mieux qu'on dit
service militaire obligatoire
même comme cheveux même pantalon même si
je fais sur donc
et heureusement nicolas pas que plus
17,8 non
ben moi ce que je peux dire ce que j'ai
appris avec raïs c'est quelque chose
tout bête mais il m'a montré ma ville ma
région sous un angle que j'avais jamais
vu il m'a montré
la ferraille
je sais aujourd'hui faire la différence
entre métaux ferreux et non ferreux on a
transporté de la ferraille ensemble on n
a fait des débats rat de cave et je peux
dire que raïs il m'a fait découvrir ma
propre ville
donc pour tard
je peux dire on a réfléchi on s'est dit
qu'est ce que c'est entreprendre
pour moi pour nous entreprendre c'est
traduire ces traduire au sens
étymologique d'amener d'un point à un
autre et le point de départ c'est un
rêve c'est un projet et il faut le
traduire dans la réalité
et c'est aussi traduire au sens courant
parce que raïs il a une idée qui vient
deux scieries et il a fallu la mener
jusqu'à la france
mon projet à l'avenir
j'aimerais bien traduit au rheu traduit
son projet cette entreprise comme il est
maintenant vers la syrie fait j'ai
jamais perdu l'espoir que les régime
dictatorial un jour va disparaît donc la
série il a besoin de décès rien pour
reconstruit et mon rêve on souhaite
tous que traduire mon pays d'origine
tout que ce jeu que le prix de ce que je
pris ici
en france mon deuxième pays voilà merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]